I have bizarre video of Donald Trump rambling
on CNBC, which has been released.
I wanted to play this yesterday.
Just ran out of time.
And among the really strange comments that
Trump makes a talking about Tesla founder
Elon Musk, which we'll get to because those
comments are wacky as well.
Trump seems to weirdly say that the United
States invented the wheel or that an American
inventor or an American entrepreneur invented
the wheel.
It's very weird video.
Let's take a look at it.
Tufts was now worth more than GM and Ford.
Do you have comments on Ilan Muff?
Well, you have to give him credit that I spoke
to him very recently and he's also doing the
rockets.
He likes rockets and uh, he does good at rockets
too, by the way.
I never saw where the engines come down with
no wings, no anything and their landing.
I said, I've never seen that before.
And I was worried about him because he's one
of our great geniuses and we have to protect
our juniors.
You know, we have to protect Thomas Edison
and we have to protect all of these people
that, uh, came up with originally the light
bulb and the wheel and all of these things.
And he's one of our very smart people.
And we want to, we want to cherish those people.
That's very important.
But he's done a very good job.
Uh, shocking.
How well, you know how it's come so fast.
I mean, you go back a year and they were talking
about the end of the company and now all of
a sudden they're talking about these great
things.
He's going to be building a very big plant.
So there's a lot here.
Let's start with the wheel.
Okay.
And then we'll talk about Elon Musk.
One of the great inventions, or maybe it's
a discovery in human history, was that of
the wheel.
Now I say invention or discovery because the
physics concept of what a wheel is and what
a wheel does as a way to move mass or to uh,
accomplish work of different kinds.
It existed in nature for a long time, but
we can also say that it was invented in some
specific forms by humans and applied to our
problems.
In any case, that's a different debate whether
the wheel was invented or discovered.
It happened a very long time ago, probably
the late neolithic.
We have examples of wheels actually from about
4,500 BC, the Potter's wheel, the wheeled
vehicles that happened in conjunction with
domesticating horses.
That's 6,500 years ago.
Trump wants to protect great American inventors
like those who involve, invented the wheel.
This is a very strange thing to say.
Now, the other side of it, the cartoonish
part is we've got to protect our great American
inventors who invented the wheel.
The other part is he seems to consider Elon
Musk, one of our great geniuses, our great
geniuses.
He says, remember that Elon Musk is South
African, not American.
And I wonder whether South African immigrants
are the people that Donald Trump envisions
inviting to the United States.
Uh, given his view of what immigration should
be in the United States is South Africa in
the Norway category or the S whole country
category in the mind of Donald Trump.
I don't know.
Uh, but it seems to be completely missed on
Trump that his anti-immigration stance is
completely at odds with the countless immigrant
entrepreneurs that he often cites as the people
we want more of like Elon Musk and Trump seemingly
talking about both Elon Musk and the wheel
as products of the United States of America.
When of course, neither is more incoherence
from a president.
That seems to be very, very unwell.
Tell me what you make of make of it.
I'm on Twitter at Dee Pacman.
Follow me.
Follow the David Pakman show on Twitter as
well at David Pakman show.
We will get to your phone calls later on in
the show.
I am going to address this question of Trump's
responsibility for the Ukrainian airliner
that was down by Iran.
A lot of people wrote in and said, David,
can you give us a sense of what responsibility,
if any, does Donald Trump have for that?
I also got a bunch of people writing to me
after in the last democratic debate.
I said, Tom Stier did better than a lot of
people.
Tom Stire did better than Buddha.
Judge Tom Stier did better than club car and
some other people.
People said, David, who would you vote for?
Biden or Stier?
I'm going to address that later today.
And then lastly, the question of what type
of a running mate would a Bernie or Warren
nominee be best, uh, in
formed to consider.
We will talk about that later on in the program
as well.
Quick break phone calls, questions a lot more
coming up today